eliezer hernandez 10th start of the
season
not a cold strike three not a bad way to
start for hernandez
always fun to watch juan soto still in
the mix some might say for an mvp
absolutely alive for a batting title
20s for juan soto who smokes one toward
right center field that's going to get
all the way to the wall another extra
base hit for him and still cruise into
second base with a two-out double here
in the first now such good balance
you're not going to make a mistake
inside the strike zone and think that
it's going to get past soto
josh bell hitting 257 kicks and fires
and this ball is lifted high into the
air but it'll be caught by the center
fielder de la cruz
11th start this season and in the career
of josiah gray second time he's facing
the marlins well miguel rojas comes to
bat
that is gonna sneak through for a base
hit into right field
sanchez who's batting 244. a 3-2 from
gray
is outside for ball four and mickey
takes third
lewis was over four in last night's game
the seven to one washington win
the pitch is swung on and missed
brenson's down on strikes and none of it
hernandez batting 272.
that last weekend on a pitch up
hernandez deep center de la cruz still
going so's the ball see
you
later
straight away number nine for yadiel
hernandez here's alex avila
on a pitch heavy rips it to right center
garcia the second baseman hitting 239.
and on that pitch up he jacks one deep
left center
de la cruz back and that is off the wall
avila had to hold up just a bit
stand up double
catcher to third
lane thomas
got the express caught looking first
time
and the pitch in on the hands swung on a
missed strike three thomas is down
well he got one to work with there
and the streak continues first time up
juan soto 100
and what was it 17 mile an hour double
oh
out ahead of that one
see
you
later juan soto
that was a clean lift right out of the
ballpark and the nats lead three nothing
on his 27th rbi's number 88 and 89.
it doesn't power clean
a lot of his swing came with his hands
in his arms
fastball up and in how about those hands
and arms
see
you
later
second deck
dan will let you continue in a moment
but it's four nothing gnats
nothing in one on brinson
brinson left center field toward the gap
it will get down
but i'll find thomas but brinson will
get into second base with a two out
double
legwin fanned in the second
that's in the left center field it'll
drop in for a basic brinson's coming
around third and he'll score
leigh diaz with an rbi single and the
marlins are on the board
try to turn a double play if one or the
other gets their hands on the ball but
neither will the pitch is high and
outside and another walk hadn't walked
anybody through four now back to back
walks escobar moves to second soto goes
to first well stephen oakert is ready to
go josh bell is as well
that one to third
alvarez to jazz and onto first hand
picked out of the dirt by diaz into the
left-hand hitter
yada yall hernandez
this one's in the air out towards center
de la cruz
camps underneath it and makes the catch
so oaker comes in cleans up the mess and
keeps this at a four to one definition
avila singled in the second
called out on strikes in the fourth
alvarez was hit by your excuse me avila
was hit by the pitch nationals have a
base runner here in the sixth inning i
didn't think they had much of a chance
josiah gray with a base hit at least for
the moment how about that it's going to
go down as a 9-3 put out jesus sanchez
brian de la cruz with one away
for an 18.
he might have done it then too yeah juan
soto can't make the play that one's
gonna get to the wall de la cruz is
gonna run for a while he's on his way to
third base
and he's gonna stop right there
[Applause]
you got sanchez at the plate
in the center
face it for asus sanchez de la cruz will
score
and the marlins are down 4-2
escobar the batter
holding maybe because of soto
and it's dropped into right field now if
he's running
it's probably first and third there but
you'll take first and second with soto
escobar at first base with the hit and
sodos up
soto has another hit
this one heading to the gap
thomas around to score
over to third escobar
now juan soto puts the nats back on top
by three with his third rbi of the night
and number 90 on the year
the bell switch hitter batting left
and josh will elevate
certainly deep enough for escobar to
score and make it six to two yada yada
hernandez hit a solo home run
in the second
on a pitch up base hit
right inside the left field line
we're gonna track soto heading for third
took a while here comes juan chugging
home and the gnats have another run
as he rolls over in the dirt
that is severe damage oh and kibum's
going to die for it had that ball hit
the ground it might have checked up and
you never know what might have happened
at first
carter kibu
one of the best diving plays you'll see
on a 60
70 foot fly ball ever ball's not
carrying the left
layman diaz will lead things off
a couple of strikeouts but an rbi single
in the fourth inning
off the end of the bat cue shot harper
gets to it flips it over to first but an
infield single for lewin
and he's gonna stop right there fortes
homered last night for the marlins only
run of the game in the seven to one
nationals win pitch hitting here in the
ninth inning
it might work as a pinch hitter too this
one's hit to left and it's gone
two-run home run for nick fortes
[Music]
start pinch hit doesn't matter
three home runs sandy's been up now for
the third time he has struck out and
fouled out
and santa leone gives it a ride out to
right field soto's back and it's gone
second over the inning for the marlins
and they're down seven to five
[Applause]
fastball bell picks it off
he got there to the bag as tanner rainey
was struggling to get over there and the
nats win a series
and tanner rainey gets a second save of
the year
and his step back in this role could be
very important looking down the road